so one of the comments that I'm getting
quite a bit is that people have noticed
that I recommend send it from the Syrian
and his poems the hymns of paradise 2 to
read that in order to understand the
story in Genesis and also the symbolic
structure and many people have written
me to say that they're not they're
struggling to get out of sin Ephraim
what I suggest they can get and so last
month I was invited by father Jason
foster to Shreveport Louisiana to speak
at a clergy retreat for the Orthodox
Church the OCA Orthodox Church of
America but also to give to public to
public speaking events at his parish and
so what you're gonna see is the first
part of that I'll post the second part
in a few weeks but the first part was
really diving into the palm of Saint
Ephrem also connecting that poem with
sangria Gaurav Nisa and his vision of
the ascent of the mountain and so what
we're really getting is this image of
the mountain of paradise as this cosmic
structure and so hopefully this will
help people get through Saint Ephrem and
get the golden nuggets that are found in
his poem I would especially recommend
that people a lot of the good stuff came
out in the question period because it
was the first time I was presenting
trying to present these things
systematically a lot of the stuff ended
up coming out in the question period so
please if you can take the time to to
get through that as well the questions
are difficult to understand but what I
when they are I put up the question as
text over the image and so if you are
listening to it audio maybe take a
glance at the screen to see the question
if you want to follow that as well so
please enjoy my first dive into Center
from the Syrian and I hope you enjoy
that
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so tonight what I want to talk about is
I want to talk to you a little bit about
that experience that I had or try to
take you along that experience that I
had of seeing how everything is
connected together to see how the Bible
and our tradition of the father's the
icons all of this is really a powerful
series of embedded patterns you could
call it I the way I sometimes try to
describe it is that it reality has a
fractal structure already know what a
fractal is so fractal is like a tree if
you look at a tree you have the basic
tree but then each branch of the tree
has the same shape as the tree alright
so you have a tree and then the branch
and on if you follow the branch if you
could cut the branch off and hold it it
would look just like a tree if you'd cut
a smaller branch off it would also look
like a tree because the pattern is the
basic pattern but then at every level of
the tree it's the same pattern which
reappears and that's what when you start
to look at the way that the father's
were interpreting scripture and the way
that then they use that and they they
use that to form our liturgy to form our
icons to form the way that they talked
about scripture that that's what they're
diving into they're diving into that
pattern and so when a father will add
some what we'll go through some of the
detail when the father will add some
little detail in the text it looks like
he's making up some detail in the
biblical text some tradition but he's
not he's able to say that because he's
noticed that there's all these patterns
come together and the elements are there
in each one so this is very abstract for
now I can take you on the trip so
hopefully you will you will you will see
what I'm talking about
so first of all we have this idea this
embedded idea of patterns you could call
it the father's st. Maximus the
Confessor especially talks about it as
macrocosm and microcosm so there's a
cosmic structure and then there's a
personal structure the human being is
microcosm and then you have this massive
universe which has the same shape as the
human person so st. Maximus goes very
far in this he says the entire cosmos
consisting of the visible and invisible
things is man and man consisting of body
and soul is cosmos for the intelligible
things participate to the substance of
the soul as the soul have the same
reason add the intelligible one's
actually more complicated stick keep the
first quote part but I'm still going to
go through and they're sensible things
bear the image of the body as the body
and the image of the sensible things so
we have in the created world there are
invisible things there are
principalities there are the Angels
they're things that hold that they hold
the world together then we have sensible
things and in the person we also have an
invisible aspect to us we have the soul
we have the news we have we have even
have our our desires which are invisible
and then there's the body there's the
physical part and those two are they're
the same structure so because they're
the same structure st. Maximus sees
creation as being built for men because
man ends up being the thing that holds
the whole thing together like this is
like an anchor that has just like the
universe has a physical aspect and
invisible spiritual aspects and then
kind of brings it all together so st.
Maximus talks about how the man is a he
talks about him as being a laboratory in
which because the human being pulls all
those elements together right we have
our thoughts we have our bodies you have
all these elements to us and we pull
them together into one being and then
the human being does that also for
creation itself and so it's interesting
it's interesting too
think about that it's interesting to
think about that today because we're
we're reaching we've gone through this
time in history where we've had this
kind of scientific materialism and we
and Christians have been slapped around
by a lot of that that thinking where we
have this idea that there's the world
the world has these rules and we just
have to look at them and could measure
we can calculate and then we can just
say you know hear how here's how it
works we figured it out
but we're coming - we're coming to the
end of that and even a lot of scientists
a lot of physicists are coming to the
end of that where they realize once
we've reduced everything to the material
world once we've done that we have a
problem
because then you have to explain the
spiritual stuff it's high because before
that they could kind of ignore it yeah
this is stupid
this is just stupid stuff let's not talk
about that we're just going to talk
about this material stuff then you reach
the end of it you're like okay we can
encompass everything in this material
stuff we've encompassed everything and
then at some point you're like okay well
then let's take that stuff that
spiritual stuff like consciousness like
human experience like identities like
qualities of things how do you now fit
that into your material world and
they're struggling to do it so they come
up with words like emergence right how
how is it why is it that we know that
something has parts but it's also one
thing at the same time your thought
about that all right you look at a chair
the chair has parts right it has
different parts of it elements different
yeah why do we think that that's one
thing why do we say it's a chair why
don't we just see the parts why don't we
just see the parts all the way down
because those parts go all the way down
in the scientific world all the way down
to this to the quantum whatever a
quantum field of particles that are just
floating around so then they stack up
they stack up towards these different
stages of unity and then in the human
experience we we we've seen even more
you know like why do we think that this
here people coming here why do we think
that that's one thing why do we think
that the United States of America is one
thing how do we get to that all right
and so in the vision of st. Maximus same
axis gives us a key same axis gives us a
key is that the human person a modern
way of saying that maybe something like
consciousness right pop fathers don't
use that word but it's a good word to
use because people understand what it
means today people know a lot of the
other words like soul you say use the
word soul today your people just have
all these ideas of what it means like
it's try to try to find words that
actually have meaning for people today
so you say so you say - we need
consciousness or consciousness plays a
part in bringing things together in
making things one right you need a
conscious agent to be able to say that
tear is a bunch of stuff it's also one
thing that jump into into unity and
that's how same access talks about us
that's what we do that's when we are
that's what that's what makes us special
in creation that's what makes us not
only special that's what makes us in the
image of God all right so that's this
idea of this macrocosm microcosm right
and how relevant it is to understand
today one of the words that the
physicists are using today they they
they have a fancy theory they call it
the anthropic principle because they're
realizing that anthropic means the shape
like the shape of of men they realize I
realized that it's so complicated
everything is so complicated then you
almost need the world to be made in a
way to give consciousness to bring
consciousness about this consciousness
is they're not able to explain it they
can't explain consciousness but they
can't explain the thing by which they're
looking at the world with comes very
great and then that's when people like
say max my student help us get a key to
something more all right so a lot of you
like me come from kind of Bible
believing churches the kind of
Protestant and yellow
world so what I discovered in reading
the Church Fathers and today I'm gonna
take you mostly through a church father
whose name is Saint Ephrem mysterium San
Deborah the Syrian is a Semite he's a
he's an Arab air Mia Aramaic Saint who
probably spoke Aramaic he actually did I
know it wasn't air maybe Pope the early
Syriac language I would think I think
his sexes are written in Syria
um and so he does this powerful
interpretation of the Garden of Eden and
of Genesis he has a text called the
hymns on paradise and it's a poem it's a
poem that talks about paradise but the
way that you talks about paradise is so
powerful because it does exactly what
I'm talking to you about it shows us
this pattern that is there it basically
lays the Garden of Eden out as the
pattern of everything all the way until
we understand that it's also the pattern
of the part of the human person alright
so first off I want to show you how big
yeah how big Saint Ephrem makes the
paradise he says he had a vision like
for him if he had this this vision of
paradise and he says with the eye of my
mind I gazed upon paradise the summit of
every mountain is lower than its some
okay so it's the highest mountain and
then he talks about how the crest of the
flood of Noah reached to the foothills
of paradise but it didn't enter into
paradise and so paradise ended up being
above the flood okay
now you also have to remember that
paradise is a mountain right that's not
actually in the Bible people forget that
it's in the Bible it's not in Genesis
it's in Ezekiel in Ezekiel Ezekiel give
this description of paradise and he says
you talked about paradise as the as this
holy mountain as this mountain so you
have to imagine this mountain now I'm
already going to give you the image
and so he has this idea of this paradise
as a mountain at the summit of the
mountain is the Tree of Life right and
let's say above the Tree of Life or
coming down upon the Tree of Life
is the glory of God just like the glory
of God descended onto the Ark of the
Covenant he has he does he talks about
how the blue or that the glory of God
descended to encounter Moses on the
Mount Sinai so to the glory of God is at
the summit of the mountain and we have
the Tree of Life so he talks about how
the limits of the garden so imagine that
so the summit of the garden is higher
than all the mountains and the limit of
the garden is beyond all the ocean so
you imagine the way that the ant ancient
people saw the world basically this
giant island surrounded by Oceanus by
the infinite ocean which is still true
today there still is this ocean that
kind of surrounds everything you know
that's all connected together that kind
of flows around everything and so he saw
the paradise as the limits of paradise
being beyond the ocean here's a
description that he that he talks about
he says Moses made a crown for that
resplendent altar with the wreath
entirely of gold that he crowned the
altar in its beauty right so around the
altar in the tabernacle there was this
this golden brave or this golden crown
which went around the altar so he says
thus gloriously intertwine is the wreath
of paradise that in certain circles the
whole of creation so the crown of
paradise the wreath of paradise
encircles all of creation so its summit
is beyond the highest mountain and its
limit is beyond all of creation so so
already we're trying we're starting to
see that the place that he's talking
about is maybe not
the same kind of place that we're used
to thinking about in our and a very
materialistic world let's say that he is
talking about a place but this place is
is it's a it's the place of places you
could call it fragrance then it's that
which makes place possible something
like that and maybe waited to describe
it
and so this mountain is also higher it's
a hierarchy of beings or hierarchy of
being itself so here's some descriptions
that he gives he says when he made this
intricate design he varied its beauties
so that some levels were far more
glorious than others to the degree that
one level is higher than another so too
is its glory the more sublime in the in
this way he alots the foothills and the
most lowly the slopes to those in
between and the heights to the exalted
so that which is exalted that which is
high that which is glorious is higher up
on this mountain and that which is
confused or in between or is lower is
lower on the mountain all right so
hopefully things are starting to take
shape and understanding what he's
talking about
so then say saint ever talks about the
four rivers of paradise so we know that
in the garden there were four rivers of
paradise now if you if you think of the
paradise as a mountain right all of a
sudden the image of the four rivers will
change as well because you it's hard you
can't really see it otherwise as these
four rivers that are coming down the
mountain so you can kind of in Mack I
mean you don't have to think about it
too much but like a source there's a
source some kind of source that is
pushing the water and then it's coming
down coming down the mountain so he
talks about
how its fountains delight with their
fragrance but when they issue forth
towards us they become impoverished in
our country since they put on the savers
of our land as we drink them so we had
this idea that the waters of the rivers
of paradise water all of creation they
are the source of all the waters we
always have to remember when we look at
in the Bible and it talks about water
flowing water always comes from above it
has to it has to come from above there's
no other way for it to be flowing and so
it when we talks about flowing waters
we're already in this notion of this
hierarchy the water is coming from above
it's coming from him the water is coming
from so here are these four rivers that
come down water the world and as they
look get lower and lower on this
mountain they lose their quality they
become ixed today's
talks about the beings he talks about
the children of light so he talks about
from their abodes the children of light
descent they rejoice in the midst of the
world where they had been persecuted
they dance on the surface of the sea and
they do not sink because he said Efrain
understand that paradise is is always
there it's always it's not something
which was only there in the past it's
always it's always there and then if we
want to participate in paradise there
are ways in which we participate in
paradise and he gives us the way she
tells us first of all he kept he tells
us in the Old Testament what those were
he says these this structure with this
mountain and he divides it into three so
he has the Tree of Life at the
ha and that is is the same as the Holy
of Holies of the Temple of the
tabernacle and then he has the tree of
knowledge of good and evil and that's
the same as the holy place in the
tabernacle or the temple and then he has
the lower part the the gate or the fig
tree which would be the outer court of
the tabernacle so he divided into these
three parts why is the fig tree why is
the fig tree the third part do you know
the story why there's the fig tree and
that's in that story why is there a fig
tree in the story of paradise remembers
sorry they cover themselves exactly so
that becomes the first covering so then
everything else is going to flow from
there this notion of the covering so
imagine this these levels as three
coverings three veils the three veils of
the temple you have the veil to the Holy
of Holies you have the veil to the Holy
Place and then outside you have this
rougher coverings you have the covering
of skin the garments of skin ten
different doesn't talk about the
garments of skin but saying rigor Mesa
definitely talks about the garments of
skin and he explains how the covering of
the tabernacle which was hairy it was
made of animal skins is the same as the
garments of skin that Adam and Eve put
on themselves so as we as we get lower
and lower on the on the hierarchy of
beings there is this need to cover
ourselves more right um and it's not
that hard to understand that it's not
that hard to understand it I always talk
in my in my my talks about the garments
of skin trying to understand what that
is what does it mean that Adam need had
to cover themselves with garments and it
really does have to do with this moving
out towards death
so in the garden they were
self-sufficient to the extent that they
were only dependent on God and as they
move away from the garden then they
start to become dependent on they start
to have to deal with the outside world
more and more I think the reason why God
gave Adam and Eve garments of skin was
to encounter the thorns God said because
of your fall the trees will start to
produce thorns and so the world will be
hostile to you and you have to cover
yourself in order to face that hostility
so you add a layer of clothing to be
able to face the cold then if you want
more cold you go further out into a
place where human beings it's more
difficult with the world is more hostile
to you you add a house and if you want
to go further out into a world that's
hostile to you you add a wall to your
city you add this and that and you add
technologies in order to supplement your
existence out in the world of the the
hostile world the story of the fall you
see it happening
there's the fall Adam and Eve have
garments of skin and then there's
another fall or Cain killed his brother
and then what does King do found the
city so you have this garment around
Adam and Eve and then Cain puts a
garment around around let's say the
group and then his descendants they end
up creating weapons war and steel you
know metal weapons metallurgy in order
to add that and then the final result of
that is the flood where it all breaks
apart you can't at some point that
garment you keep adding garments
around yourself at some point no cracks
and then and I went through that
recently for those who know that I've
been through a flood that our city
they built a dike at the end of our city
because they used to get flooded and
then they started to trust that dike
completely and everybody forgot that the
dike even basically existed it was like
this is just normal world
the waters rows and rows and rows and at
some point the Dyke gave in and the
water came in so these garments of skin
which are which are immediately
described by the father's as our
physical bodies that are that our
fleshly bodies are the first garments of
skin that you all know that those they
give us they give us protection for a
while but they're gonna break apart it's
better to do what you need to do while
you've got them you know because at some
point they're gonna go away all right so
so the notion is that this thing this
mountain it goes all the way out until
so I said it from have different ways of
describing it he talks about when Adam
and Eve fell then God chased them out of
the garden and then they were lower down
on the slopes of the garden and then
when a Cain killed Abel then Cain was
chased lower down still and then Seth
was higher up on the mountain so it is
it's a hierarchy of beings it's
ontological higher the more you're
closer to God to higher you up on the
mountain the further you are from God
the lower you are on this this mountain
for all of these those who are Orthodox
it's their ladder of divine ascent the
same thing the ladder of divine descent
is exactly what he's talking about here
you know several centuries before that
that text was written the the it's the
same it's the same structure okay
Saint Ephrem talks about how this is the
same structure as the ark that Noah's
Ark because the human beings were on top
and then the birds were there after
after I have lowered them the humans and
then the animals were at the bottom of
the ark like I said the same as the
tabernacle the tabernacle had the glory
of God at the India in the Holy of
Holies and on the outside there was the
outer court where they had these
and around the tabernacle they also had
these these animal skins that were
around it so it's it's all of it is the
same in the same structure and so then
when when when it said in the Bible that
the children of God mixed with the
daughters of men right in this he
actually gives such as able to avoid the
problem of the whole angel thing because
he he has it on a mountain and so you
have the the dog the children of Seth
the sons of Seth that go down the
mountain and then they they mix with the
daughters of King and so in they go
they're going down the ontological and
they're perpetuating this this fall like
going further and further down and then
finally like I said you have this fig
tree that was an image of the covering
and instead Ephraim does a beautiful
thing he tells us why Christ curses the
fig tree right that text which is the
one of the strangest text in the gospel
right Christ comes up to the fig tree
and he curses it because it hasn't
produced fruit Sanford says it in the
Sanford is just like just makes total
sense because that's how the fall
started Adam and he fell and they tried
to cover themselves and Christ is saying
I'm removing those coverings I'm going
to remove them and in the process he in
the prophets it's also in the story of
his entry into Jerusalem he's going
towards crucifixion he removes the the
garments of the fig garments and then he
ends up by ripping the last veil in the
temple and entering into the holy of
holies and so Christ is going he's going
back up he's doing it in reverse he's
going wait he's going back up the
mountain in that in that story
part of it is cursing the fig tree all
right
so does that does that make sense to
some of you like do you you can you kind
of see how this pattern is repeated in
Scripture in different places and the
structure of a church
the actual architectural structure of
the church follows the same structure
right our church our church architecture
has three sections basic sections we
have the altar the Holy of Holies and we
have the nave which the the communions
gather and then we have the narthex
where is the buffer space between the
outside right we chase we don't know
what he does it anymore really but in
theory we we chase the catechumens
out at a certain moment in in the
liturgy in order to create that actual
ontological higher we're actually doing
that so we have the priest in the in the
altar we have the the faithful in the
nave and have those that are in between
right remember Saint Ephrem said that
which is in between is lower on on so we
have this in between and the narthex and
then we have the flood or the
chaos on the outside right okay
hopefully I made my case for that at
least because I'm not done yet
and so because this structure exists at
all the different levels when the
Incarnation happens then it gets in like
it falls into the personal level Christ
has a person Christ is also the glory of
God which descends down on the holy
mountain that's what Christ is he is the
ultimate he is the ultimate
accomplishment of that promise of that
image of the glory of God descending and
and and coming down onto the Ark of the
Covenant coming down onto the holy
mountain all of this so inevitably the
church fathers are going to associate
who with the car did you look at the
icon right behind you if you look at the
icon to the Last Judgement there's an
image of paradise and there are two
images
two basic images of paradise in paradise
one is the bosom of Abraham right
so think about think about this
ontological hierarchy that I'm talking
to you about you have a source Abraham
then he has children they have children
they have children they have children
and it widens out right it becomes it
becomes a pyramid at Abraham Moore has
more and more children has more more
children and then when they when they
die if they're righteous where do they
go they go back they go back into their
place of origin they go back to paradise
they go back to their source they go
back to the bosom of Abraham you could
do that we could keep going on - Adam if
you wanted to then we go to Abraham but
we could all say we're all in the bosom
of Adam right but then the other image
is Mother of God because she is the
place where Christ came down and
manifested himself through and so we see
for example in this image I always tell
people the reason why we put the mother
of God in Paradise isn't just because
she's in Paradise because she is
paradise right the reason why we show
the bosom of Abraham in Paradise isn't
because the because Abraham is in
paradise - because it is paradise that
is an image of paradise okay and so the
until the the Father's will bring us on
that on that line you st. pro kleh says
the holy mother of god and Virgin Mary
has gathered us here she is the pure
treasure of virginity the intended
paradise of the second Adam so in that
net quote there's a lot of things going
on first of all she's the one who has
gathered us here what does that mean
means that the church is also paradise I
are told right it's the same that this
destruction this is this thing this is
paradise
I mean you could say it's not if you
could say that there's an eschatological
you know glorification of that reality
where at some point all creation is
going to to kind of come into this this
this ultimate revelation of return to
paradise but also the holy city like of
course but we can participate in
paradise already to the extent that we
are gathered by the holy virgin into the
church and then she is the intended
paradise for the second Abbot the second
item is of course Christ so what is it
one of the names you do some of you know
one of the names for Mount Athos
Morocco's is called the garden of the
mother of God not a great name
what do you think they're referring to
when they say the garden of the mother
of God there again the monks the holy
months in their in their divine
intuition they referring to paradise
they're telling me Athos is an image is
a participation is is a participation in
paradise and this image is one of my my
favorite the the image of of the mother
of God of the holy of holy fount where
you if you look at her she's she's
basically a mountain she's this mountain
and then you can see that the water is
flowing down from her like the water is
flowing from the mountain to paradise
there's another image as well - you have
it in your narthex which is the mother
of God as the burning bush if you look
at that icon not all the time but often
they'll make the burning bush in a way
that it fills up the entire mountain and
so it looks like the mother of God is
like a mountain inside the mountain so
you have this amazing image of the
amount amount Sinai as being as being
the mother of god herself alright
so so the returned to paradise
in the end and the father's especially
in st. gregory of nyssa who is one of my
favorite father he talks about it as the
removal of the garments of skin so he
says in order then to go back into this
space we have to remove the coverings
remove the coverings and the coverings
have to do with our passions you have to
do with our our sins and you have to
think about it because it's not it's not
arbitrary right why do we sin we often
sin because we think that that's where
life is right you think that that's we
have you have a desire to eat and those
desires are not wrong our desires none
of our desires are wrong we have a
desire for sexual sexual desire we have
all these different desires but the
problem is when we enter into that and
we think that that is going to be our
protection that if I eat then I'm fine
right if I give in to the desire then I
will find life there that I will I will
be safe right but that's why we have
ascetic practices because that's not
where true safety is that's not where
true life is so st. Gregory's have talks
about this removal of the guard the the
garments of skin but he talks about it
in the sense for example he talks about
how Moses when Moses went up into the
mountain to see the burning bush it says
that he removed his sandals in order to
enter into the holy place and Saint
Gregory will say you mean we need to
remove the garments from the feet of our
soul in order to come into the presence
of God you think about st. Paul when he
talks about he talked about the
circumcision of the heart right so he
uses the image of the Old Testament of
removing this layer of skin right
removing this layer of skin in order to
go back to something which is rectified
right to remove the layer of skin
he says no no he said yeah fine that's
that's good it's fine that the
circumcision was fine it's an image of
something which is way more ghee way
more profound which is that you need to
remove the veils around your heart you
need to remove the garments which
protect which which you use to protect
your heart or you use to cover your
heart until the entering into the the
temple the entering into paradise all of
those now come into the person where the
structure of the person ends up being
the same structure as paradise same
structure as the temple the same
structure as the church and so the
church fathers talk about this hierarchy
of be we have we have a capacity which
they talk about the noose the spiritual
intellection intellection the capacity
to grasp God to to to to to come into
contact directly with God
that's would be up there at the top of
the mountain you'll be up there you know
where the Tree of Life is and then we
have the soul part you could say that
the thoughts the feelings the the
desires all of that is in the middle
part and then at the lower part you
would have the body or you could also
understand that the passions as being in
the lower part to consist see it as a
hierarchy you have the the the noose or
the spiritual capacity the thoughts the
passions and you could imagine the body
as even being kind of outside say Saint
Ephrem he talked he has his great in it
he says that there are no animals in
paradise I think that's weird right
because in the Bible he doesn't say that
there no Hannah was in paradise he says
that I even in here I drew a different
from what Saint Ephrem describes it he
says the serpent was not in paradise
said the serpent came up to the gate of
paradise and Adam and Eve had to come
down the mountain in order to encounter
the the serpent at the gate okay and so
this idea that the church fathers always
attached our bodies to the
like the animality mean it's not stupid
it's obviously true that is what we have
in common with the animals you know that
the evolutionists evidence the fight
Church Fathers knew that our bodies we
have in common with the a no that's not
a surprise do we have the same structure
at the animals but this idea that they
have to descend the mountain in order to
encounter the animals so it actually
gives them it gives a very interesting
very interesting possible solution to
the problem of death this whole problem
of people talking about you know was
their death before you know how is it
that there couldn't be there could be
death before but if you see the Paradise
as an ontological higher instead of just
just seeing it as a as a story then you
understand that the animals that the the
more tap the mortality was already there
you could say down at the bottom of this
hierarchy already was already
possibility down below this this this
cosmic is causing structure I'm just
suggesting that I'm not saying that that
that's a solution but it's something
definitely something to think about all
right so I had this this this great one
of my favorite quotes from the same
Nicodemus of the holy mountain he said
he went there for keep in mind that as
the center of a wagon wheel has a
certain number of spokes going out to
the circumference of the circle and
returning to the center where they meet
so also is the heart of man like a
center where all the senses all the
powers of the body and all the
activities of the soul are united and so
you can see that structure again he
described it as a flat wheel but it
doesn't matter it's the same thing as a
as a mountain but you have a you have a
spoke Center then you have all these
things that come out which which emanate
from the center but as they get further
and further away imagine the wheel the
spokes on the wheel as they get further
away from the center what happens there
further from each other there further
from the center if you turn the wheel
what happens the further you get out the
wheel actually goes faster if you turn
the wheel the further you are on the
wheel the faster it spins the closer you
are towards the center the slower it
spins and as and if you come into the
very center of the wheel doesn't spin at
all it actually stops that the axis of
the wheel is doesn't move it's this
invisible point in a spinning circle
that doesn't does it move actually and
so this image this is it this is the
image this is this is the image when the
father's talk about going to the heart
going to the heart get to enter into
your heart it's because it's all the
senses they come into the central
invisible point this is this place in
the human person where I guess movement
stop I'm not a saint so I don't know
it's like I don't but then it also but
it doesn't mean that everything on the
outside none of it is bad right all
creation is good and it's a nephron
emphasizes that to problem isn't that
you know like the whip down on the
mountain is not is not bad but it
becomes bad to the extent that it
forgets the top right that's the church
fathers always talk about memory that's
the whole idea memory so as you in your
you have these desires on the edge of
you have these things pulling you in
different directions if you forget the
memory of God if you forget God then
that's when those things are going to
destroy that's when they're going to
devour you but if you remember God then
like sin Efrain talks about the children
of light that come down from the
mountain and participate in all of
creation they walk on water
this beautiful image of how the saint
can engage with all of creation without
it being a danger to him he's able to
come down the entire hierarchy and the
flood for him is basically a floor that
he can walk on like Christ walked on the
water so this beautiful image of how
everything participates but did you
forget what happens I don't know I have
the story of st. Peter
know what happens if you're walking on
water and then you you start to focus on
what's going on instead of focusing on
the face of your Divine Lord that's in
front of you you say and in that image
you get I can get what is what a st.
Peter say when he's sinking Lord Jesus
I'm gonna say the prayers like Lord
Jesus Christ that person doesn't say did
that exact words but that's that's the
basic thing he's saying he's saying have
mercy on me and that's our prayer right
that's that's the whole of that's the
whole of the mystical tradition of the
church is this capacity to even when
you're falling even when you're lower to
remember the glory of God that you send
it on to paradise it's all the same it's
all the same structure so I this is
everybody very silent okay
this is the first time that I talked
about this to the extent that I'm
talking about it now okay
and so I I know it's possible that I
have stretched some people maybe beyond
the breaking point and so is it okay if
I take questions is that okay I would so
what I would like to I'd like to take
questions from all of you because I know
that a lot of this stuff is you know I'm
reading this your father's I'm getting
all excited and then and I'm and I'm
seeing it in the icons and I'm seeing
this but I but sometimes yeah it's it's
it's hard to think that way we're so
used to this idea of this kind of
materialist way of understanding the
world that it's very hard to think of
these embedded realities in each other
so I'd like to open up questions for you
to what you have
you think it's so much the government or
isn't the fact that if someone receives
a garment by God like the comics is
standing protect but they say anything
to make connection and receiving the
gift versus taking they forget like the
prodigal son takes the inheritance goes
out but when it's lost its returns back
right but when everything to Satan he
comes back to center - what is so it's
all repeaters repeat the basic question
just for the recording so the question
was about the garments of skin whether
or not the the garments of skin
themselves are a problem you could say
or whether it's because they they
receive them in pride or they received
them that they took them and they didn't
receive them let's say in the proper
manner right so so here's here's that
here's this is actually a really
powerful thing for me at least to have
seen this and their fathers and seen
this in the story is that Saint Ephrem
talks about how the garments of skin the
garment that before the fall human
beings were not naked that they were
covered in glory and we hear that right
we hear that in the liturgy we hear that
in art in the kind of the Orthodox
culture that Adam and Eve were covered
in glory and then when they fell God
gave them garments of skin now what's
fascinating about that tradition is that
when you find out where it comes from
it's a pre-christian tradition it comes
from the early rabbinical era before
like just just before Christ and the
text they used to talk about how we Adam
and Eve had garments of glory is a
different reading of the word garments
of skin so when it says God gave Adam
and Eve garments of skin in the original
Hebrew or Aramaic there's a way to read
the word Garman
skill as garments glory and so there's
this idea that one can become the other
right so the so saying Ephraim I
actually talked about this he talks
about how that which is the blessing
which is like you said the blessing
which is taken in pride becomes a curse
right now then you can see it the other
way around right that's when the image
of Christ just appears to you you know
when you think that you can take the
curse in humility and turn it into a
blessing right you could take the
garments of skin you could take the
consequence of Adam's curse which is
death and that could be transformed into
garments of glory and it then then all
of a sudden that a lot of Christian
practice just makes so much sense a lot
of this notion have died yourself a lot
of a lot of the ideas about why we do
the things we do if you can see that on
the sudden everything makes so much
sense and then like the image I I always
like to use the most is to me the crown
of thorns is one of the most powerful
images in the entire Bible it's one of
the most powerful images because here is
exactly that happening God said you have
sinned because of you because of the
fall the world will produce thorns the
world will produce these spiky dead
things that will be hostile and then
Christ takes that exact consequence of
the fall and he receives it as a crown
and he flips it all around and this
whole story of the crucifixion that's
what it is all the time he's flipping it
all around he's humiliated he's beaten
they mock him they treat him mockingly
as a king but in fact he's actually
manifesting his kingship they put him on
the cross they put a sign above him
saying to mock him that he's accused the
king of Jews to shame him but it's
flipping back and he actually is the
king of Jews and the king of glory and
so that the image of Christ is
to understand that idea of the garments
of skin and you see how Christ
transforms them into these garments of
glory it's a yeah to me it's one of the
things that I've seen in the father's
and in and in the story of Christ that
has knocked me over completely you know
because all of a sudden a lot of it
starts to make sense that Christ was
really is solving the puzzle all the
time solving this puzzle right here this
puzzle that was set up right in the
beginning of Genesis Christ is solving
that puzzle yes because it cuz and also
the whole idea of lots in terms of this
idea of there's a lot of things in this
story of Christianity which is which
which have to do with this
like the fact also that the foreigner is
converted that's also really part of
this because in saint gregory of nyssa
and constantly describe the garments of
skin as the egyptians in exodus he talks
about you know he talks about how moses
killed the Egyptian and killing the
Egyptian is related to circumcision
circumcision is related to baptism and
then all of that it's like killing this
idea of getting rid of that which is for
removing the garments of skin right and
so oh we do need to do that removing of
the garments of skin you see Christ he
actually takes the foreigner right and
he makes them into his glory right he
takes Rome he takes the bat [ __ ] of
Babylon he takes the though those that
destroy Jerusalem those that killed him
and then flips that completely upside
that it's pretty yes it's my book
yeah
whoa yes it's a form of hiding the
garments of skin are they do end up
being a form of hiding and I mean come
on we all know that that's what it is
that's why I wear clothes to hide myself
but that but then a lot of the actions I
have out in the world
this false thing that I present to you
guys know and end up you know my you
know like my pretensions my all of these
things that I present you there way to
hide something obviously we all have
that you all kind of engage in that
transaction I would say maybe it's just
me
[Laughter]
and so this what's amazing in their
story in saint gregory of nyssa
especially is amazing is that st.
Gregory talks about removing the
garments of skin right so he had this
image of Moses drowning the Egyptians in
the Red Sea right so that's baptism
going down leaving the garments of skin
at the bottom of the water then as he
ascends moving his sandals and then
shedding not just that but in and Saint
Ephrem talks about this also is that on
Sinai there's this hierarchy that sets
itself up because the people are at the
bottom worshiping the golden calf right
then you have the the priests which are
higher up then you have Aaron who's
higher up and holy Moses goes to the
summit so as Moses is ascending he sheds
this quantity shed this quantity
he leaves the people down below and they
end up worshiping the animal right and
then he leaves the the others and he
even leaves his own brother
and then he ascends into the holy place
and so he sheds all these garments as
he's going into the presence of God but
then when he enters into the presence of
God he's given the plans for the
tabernacle which is amazing right
because in the tabernacle there are
garments of skin and so say Gregor ISA
actually
he deals with that he says don't be
offended by the fact that here he is he
ascends this whole thing he sheds all
these garments then we need he attained
the highest point he encounters the
garments of skin and he says he says
that that it is an image of their
crucifixion right where Christ fully and
you could say fully embodied the whole
question of the garments of skin but
even more than that it's saying that as
you shed the garments you you get them
back right because there's nothing wrong
with them
like I said they become these garments
of glory there's nothing wrong with our
body nothing wrong with our passions
there's nothing that all of it is good
God created it good problem is that is
that they're not in their proper place
but they're always they they try to pull
on the blanket and be everything right
our passions they try to convince us
that that's all we are and add but if
you if you ask I mean I tell you this I
like I said I'm not a saying I did not
get it I've never entered into the
divine darkness so just know that but if
you trust the father's they talk about
this process so we can get glimpses of
it though we get these little glimpses
because we when we do when we are able
to shed some passion then we we can see
that our dependency on that passionless
some so silly how is it that I was so
taken up by that how is it that I
thought that this was all that I was
there was all my life
yep right well there's definitely that
there's definitely relationship between
the two or I mean we see it in the story
of Christ Christ comes down then he
ascends and he promises that he's going
to return and when he returns he's going
to bring a judgment he's going to set
he's going to settle it all everything's
going to be set when he comes back and
so I think that for sure this this
notion of there is this idea of ascent
and descent and I think that you get
that you get that in the father's as
well I mean and the whole idea of an
anesthetic who reaches theosis but then
you know out of love and out of mercy
and out of grace will then give us his
teachings will give us you know and we
can participate in you know a little bit
of what he has encountered you know by
our capacity to to interact with them
you know even the Saints it's the same
rank we the Saints they they they help
us to participate in something that
they've reached and we haven't yet
reached they kind of bring us up with
them we hope the to bring us up with
them yes Father
one thing fundamentally what we're
talking about is human beings and that's
multiple cultures tire pattern so we're
engaging isn't just abstract theology
it's our what it means to us
Greece Plato their style of the
marketing their movies the direction
they're talking about the same place but
the human being is your estate be free
partake of my soul and for us to be
human is and the purpose is from those
three good functioning according to the
mind with the body the soul or body and
thus coming to that state how do we do
that by the in through the sacraments
the church - understand
right okay well I have I don't know if
I'm gonna give you the I'll give you the
answer that I understand yeah that's all
I can give you is so in order for in
order for this to happen let's say on an
individual level it also has to be
happening at all levels has to stack up
and it can't just happen that's that
that's the mistake that a lot of modern
religious you know attitudes take is
they just mean that it's not just doing
God because all of these things stack up
the pattern of you is the pattern of
what a community and then it's also the
pattern of the world you know and so
Christ gives us a way for it to all
stack up and and the sacraments and
communion that's that's it he takes the
things that he takes a lot of Communion
is hard to talk about let's talk a
little bit he takes the most basic the
basic images of what uniting together is
so there's the eating together right
there's also certain sexual imagery of
the bride and the groom joining and so
all of this he kind of gives us as this
point that we all come to and we all
surround but he adds his scandal in it
to he goes all the way to Christ always
goes all the way to the edge goes all
the way to the edge and he says
something as crazy as eat flesh and
blood like that is just crazy to say
that but you have to understand like I
said what Christ is doing Christ is
saying all of this I'm gonna bring all
of this up together I'm gonna give it
I'm gonna bring it up all of it none of
its gonna be left over and so he takes
the most scandalous image right of
offering us his own body and blood
something which is completely forbidden
and even in terms of sacrificial
language that the the priest would eat
the bread of the sacrifice he never
would ever drink the blood of Zacharias
every blood had to go down into the
ground the Christ isn't all of it all of
it I'm bringing all of this together and
so and so to participate in communion is
really to to come together as a
community then also as we do that we
also have to go to confession that we
have to to come right in ourselves but
then we also are communing with the
entire cosmos the whole thing all the
way to the edge and then and we talk
about also how we are uniting with the
angels as well during the moment of
communion all of this is coming together
and this image of communion especially I
mean it is this it is this
eschatological moment it is a moment
that beyond all moments you know return
to paradise but also the holy city all
of that the beginning in the end Oh
smash together everything smashed
together in communion it's hard to think
about communion probably best not to
actually try the church fathers or these
it doesn't shut up about community
5-minute stuff now
paradise
hmm
well for sure in Saint Ephrem he really
does talk about he warns us in some I
think I have someone who cooks like he
warns us to be careful when we're
talking about paradise he says that
these things that he describes in
Paradise are names like he said be
careful of the names that we use to
describe paradise because paradise is is
he he flirts with the idea that it is
like a purely spiritual description that
he's doing but in other places he seems
to really talk about it as a place and I
think that I think that if we understand
it is a place it has to be a place right
but it's a place I think that it's it's
a place which brings all places together
I don't know how else to say and I in in
it the way that Saint Ephrem describes
it it's definitely not a place you could
find on the map that for sure I think
that theory is really impossible to
imagine that the way that he describes
how you know it's like the summit is
beyond everything and the base is beyond
the ocean it's really tough to think
that it's it's the whole map you know
it's everything coming together and so I
don't know in terms of the in terms of
the actual rivers that we use those
names for today like how he would have
understood their relationship to - to
that I sadly I don't know does that kind
of answer your question it's tough it's
tough stuff to think about it and stuff
to talk about this stuff too
all right so the the image the image of
the the last image in Revelation is so
amazing because it recapitulates the
fall in Genesis right I told you we all
would forget we read the genealogies
people who need to read the genealogies
in the Bible they're amazing but do you
have great stuff in it so when they
described the genealogy of the of the
fall up to the flood it talks about how
Cain built the city Cain builds the city
not Seth the Fallen One builds the city
and and and and that movement towards
the city leads to the flood and more and
all that and in the Old Testament
there's a there's weird stuff about that
- like Solomon has to get horn King to
build the temple if there's weird stuff
and it has to be a foreign King which
sends the Jews back to Israel to build
their walls around Jerusalem is this
weird relationship between the city the
construction the stable construction and
this interaction with the stranger the
foreigner or something like that but
then in and Canaan represents the
ultimate let's say foreigner or stranger
or whatever but then when you get to the
end of Revelations then it all is taken
in together the city that the fall you
have the tree in the middle and the city
on the edge well here you have the same
image that the tree in the middle and
you have the city around it but now it's
too glorious now it's this glorious city
which participates which is fully
remembers let's say the name of God and
so participates in this totality and so
you know the New Testament is always an
answer to this problem in the Old
Testament and I keep telling people that
puzzle first chapters of Genesis are
like a massive puzzle and then we're
given the key you know in the in the New
Testament
I see yeah yeah the in the Bible there
are several very powerful images of that
exactly and sometimes it's presented
both ways sometimes it's presented as
God remembering someone or someone
remembering God and so in in the story
of the flood for example they go out
into the flood and then when it's been
all this time it says God remembered
Noah that's it that's the connection and
then Jonah when Jonah goes down into the
fish go to the bottom of the of the the
the ocean then after three days it says
Jonah remembered God so it doesn't
matter doesn't matter where you are
right it's just depends which direction
you're facing you get that sense - if
you look at the this notion of the
divine ladder right so you you no matter
where you are on that ladder if you're
looking up and you're moving up then
you're you're good but if you turn even
if you're at the top you're gonna fall
like it doesn't matter where you are and
so this idea of memory is really this
this possibility of connecting to
something when it's far away
that's when then it is like if I if I
remember my parents that's I'm connected
to my parents even though they're far
away from me and if I forget my parents
then and then they start to fragment and
you know I start to - - I'm not
connected to them anymore so communion
could be the perfect memory you could
call it like it's perfect memory in the
sense that it is obviously we're not
physically sitting in the height you're
not physically sitting in that room when
Christ is giving out
the bread and the wine but it is we're
perfectly participating in that event to
perfect memory
so although we are two thousand years
later although we are hundreds no
thousands of miles away we have the
capacity to to fully remember that
moment and therefore participated in
fully so that's the idea and when you
hear the father I'm going to talk about
the memory of God they know that if you
remember God then you are you you're
connected to God no matter where you are
it could be in it and you get the sense
you get that also in the story of the
prodigal son fraud of the son goes all
the way out and then all of a sudden you
remembers his father it's like okay what
am i doing and what I should be in my
father's house and already he's starting
his salvation started right there and no
matter where you are and that's the
amazing thing about Christianity too is
that no matter where you are there's the
possibility if you're the worst you know
thief murderer whatever whatever
anything that you've done doesn't mean
that you're fine where you are but if
you remember God you you can get on that
road back if there's a there's a road
for you to come back if you just
remember God and so does that kind of
help a little bit but everything works
that way okay so that's like I keep
talking about how that's the structure
we have it that's is that that's like
that's what it is for everyone so you
have a you have a any object I was using
the image of a cup people are gonna get
a new exhaust you descendants of a cup
so you have a cup it's a cup has a an
identity it has a cup miss something
that makes you the cup then it also has
parts and it's made of stuff it has
parts of the handle it has a height it
has a it has it's made of stuff right I
can make that cut forget it's cut this I
can throw it to the ground Smash Ball
it's forgotten it's forgotten
it's Cutlass it's lost its unity it's
fragmented it's it's broken its parts
have stopped being assembled together
and so when that happens
when the part stop commuting with the
whole that's forget and then but if you
remember then that's how they hold
together right and that's how even
objects exist in the world they exist
through memory they have an identity and
they have parts which remember their
identity we participate in that it's
through access through it's through us
being the the laboratory of the uniting
things together we we make that not not
to our not to our personal thing but as
humans human nature participates in that
existence but if that's how the world
exists hope that make sense
yeah
right yeah it's a grittier visa talks
about I think I have a bunch of spokes
and I st. Gregory's has an amazing quote
where he talks about okay here's here
too this is a great quote the st.
Gregory Lisa says liability to death
then taken from Brut creation this idea
that I was talking about this
ontological hierarchy which lets a
potentiality or death at the bottom so
liability to death was taken from brute
creation was provisionally made to
envelop the nature created for
immortality it enrapt it externally but
not internally it grasped the sentient
part of man but laid no hold upon the
divine image which could be called like
the heart of heart to consider right
Christ seen the logos hidden in your
heart now he says the sentient heart
this outer part does not disappear but
is dissolved disappearance is the
passing away into non-existent but
dissolution is the dispersion again into
the constituent elements of the world
which of which it was composed that's
death death is center cannot hold
Things Fall Apart that's death because
when things break apart from what it is
that held them together so that image of
the garden right that's it this mountain
further you go down the mountain the
farther you are from the top but also
the farther you are from the other
things that are coming down the mountain
it's that's what fragmentation does it
not only does it isolate us from our
source but it also isolates us from each
other
right that's what that's when
communities break down that nihilism
that that people are feeling today is
because not only are we no longer in
communion in the sense that we are all
turned towards the altar all turned
toward God all turned towards Christ but
we because we have stopped doing that
we're also not able to commune with each
other and that is also we're being
further and further away from each other
and that loneliness that people feel is
a consequence
the incapacity to not and people who are
trying to just find ways to to connect
people here at the Marg and connect
people up but it's not gonna happen
it doesn't happen unless you all look in
the same direction unless we're all
moving towards the center you can do
what you want around here but it's going
to be tinder that's what it's gonna be
it's not gonna be real connect
connection it's gonna be artificial
superficial you know passionate
connections but it's not going to be the
real thing unless we turn towards the
middle unless we turn towards the Tree
of Life toward the altar towards the
glory of God which is in the middle and
we all move in that direction that's
when we start to get closer to each
other goes together so a lot of the
efforts of people who do now to say like
oh we're gonna help these young people
no it's a very provisional it's not
gonna it's not in the long-term
there's only we need something common to
look towards sadly sometimes that
sometimes people will find short gap
like measures to get that and that's
where a lot of a lot of the weird stuff
we're seeing here today like coming up
today like the kind of identitarian ISM
that we're seeing that's that's what it
is
it's a short gap it's like saying okay
we're breaking apart we need to find
these things to bring this together
until we attach ourselves on these
little identities that we have whether
it's on the right or the left you know
you say oh all this and let's let's use
this as our common thing so we can come
together but that yeah give me dangerous
yeah sorry yeah exactly yeah and
ultimately that wheel if it remembers
its center could be causing it could fly
it's as big as the cosmos right
everything is connected and yet in the
middle yes go ahead
yes yeah
well there for directions
there are everything in the sense that
they're there you can imagine that's
going in the four directions so if you
look at if you look at look like purging
Gardens you get a sense of this right
there's that there's a fountain in the
middle and then there are these four
rivers that go out in the four
directions I mean it's a cross it just
it's a crosses across is is it's kind of
everything reduced to the smallest that
eased up let's say this the most
condensed way to represent everything is
a cross because it's an extension in one
direction an extension in the other keep
going it's fills up everything sorry
it's it's it's the four directions were
probably the best way to understand that
it's like it's an extension out into the
world the basic extension to fill up
everything would be for right does that
make sense yeah wait let me just finish
that that's why there are also four
Gospels right that's why there are four
beasts on the the cherubim all right so
it's like these four things that are on
all the directions right
yeah well the tower Babel is the same
story as as as the garden it's the same
story right so so this is on I didn't go
into in the in this explanation but
Saint Ephrem is he reads a Nephilim
seriously it's amazing Saint Ephrem he
presents Adam as in being in the middle
of the garden so he presents Adam and
Eve as being at the tree of good and
evil that's where they are so God puts
Adam and Eve in the middle of the garden
between the Holy of Holies and the let
you know the outer court thank you and
so so so what so what sin Ephraim says
which is amazing this is an amazing
solution there's so many problems next
time you be the gnostic this is the
solution to this problem okay so so so
ephraim says that God put Adam there and
told him not to eat the fruit but he
didn't tell him not to eat the fruit
because he didn't want him to eat the
fruit he told him not to eat the fruit
because he wanted Adam to to obey he
wanted Adam to be humble regarding that
which was above had to have he had to be
in his place in this ontological heart
and sin effort literally says that if
Adam had obeyed and not taken the fruit
God would have given him the fruit God
would have given him the fruit so that
he could ascend and commune with the
tree of life and commune with the glory
of God right and so because he took it
out of pride so when he ate the tree of
good he says when you eat the tree of
good and evil both your eyes open you
could say your right eye and your left
eye the right eye sees the glory of God
and then the left eye sees the the
bottom of the mountain right and so what
God wanted was for Adam to in obedience
receive the fruit so that when he
ascended
that he ascended the mountain he would
he would see both sides as well right he
would see the lower side and the top
side but he would see it as someone who
is healthy understands what sickness is
whereas now because he took it out of
pride and out of self-sufficiency the
opposite happened and he got free of
this thing up there he actually was
afraid of it that's why he had to cover
himself can deal with it
so he had to cover himself then he falls
and now ascend ephraim says now he has
to learn about wellness from sickness
and it's going to be a long road my
friend it's gonna be a long road and so
the Tower of Babel is the same thing the
tower Babel is saying we're going to
reach heaven we're good at we're gonna
build the mountain we're gonna build a
mountain you got chased us from that
mountain
I'm gonna build a map we're gonna go out
and we're gonna get what's up there
what's the result
fragmentation forgetting incapacity to
commune all of that it's the same story
it's actually a good way to understand
what the garden is talking about because
you actually do get this idea of a
breaking of communion as they literally
go in different directions from this
that's this thing and they they can't
communicate with each other because they
try to take it out of self-sufficiency
out of pride and that that's the thing
that's why pride is so bad because pride
is not understanding where you are on
this hierarchy thinking that you have
like in yourself say Gregor if he says
this amazing quote he says he talked
about how sin is sin is the capacity for
non-being to think that it's V basically
capacity there's something which doesn't
have being in itself to somehow think
that they're self sufficient and then by
doing that they they will break apart
you've lost the ultimate thing that
joins you together you've forgotten it
forgotten that all of this is connected
together this pyramids all this this
hierarchy up all the way up to the
eternal you know transcendent God if you
cut that then things starts to break
apart because you forget that all of
this all this
a logical hierarchy leads up you know to
our unity in the logos so that's it's
it's this like I keep telling you be
it's a description of reality it's not
arbitrary this is how things work I do
think so yeah yeah the yeah he said the
I kind of cyanide asana icon the famous
icon with the two different eyes where
one is kind of looking straight and the
other one's kind of looking off but his
left eye is looking off and his looks a
bit angry and his and his right eye is
is looking straight at you and his kind
of appease or calm yeah I think that
definitely has to do with this right I
left I think but that's a long story if
you want I gave it there's a talk on my
youtube channel called sacred symbol
sacred art where I go into also my
description of the of the icon of the
Last Judgement or I talked about the
right hand and the left hand and the
right I mean I don't use right eye left
eye but it's like it's the same right
hand left hand
yeah you could tell you like if you
think of Christ judging the sheep and
the goats he says to those on his right
come right he says to those on his left
move away
so imagine Christ now is the center of
this wheel it's the same so those that
are on the left side they they move away
and they go into fire and forgetfulness
and Penn State they stop being
remembering there but then they're those
that are on the right side come in to
the to the kingdom I think it's enough I
think it's enough I'm running out of
voices when I know it's enough
alright thank you everybody thank you so
much thank you
[Applause]